i love you to do that uh do you remember
jeff bezos his chick
uh her brother had a lawsuit against
jeff bezos
that chick with the lazy eye yeah the
hottest wait what happened
was married and before the before the
divorce was finalized he moved around
with another chick i think she was a
news reporter
she has a [ __ ] guy but she's lauren
sanchez he's fine she's fine
she got that communion can i see you
yeah i was about to say i don't know let
let me be the judge of the mind how
could you
but peep this no her eyes [ __ ] dude i
know [ __ ] up i know he said about that
one girl
i know as we just see this she's a
baddie i mean no her eyes are fine
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't tell i mean
no go to that picture you can tell
there's a few
i mean he also has hey look her eyes are
fine there but he has also a lazy yeah
he has a sniper
yeah so one eye is bigger than the other
i love a girl with a little lazy eye on
them they back oh me too
she's a news reporter she what i don't
know if she's still doing it i don't
think she doesn't want anything anymore
but i'm here to jeff bezos
so the lady so his wife that he'd look
at her either
look at his eye yeah that's a oh my okay
so we just call it channel i
continue channel i that's the news um
but the
his ex-wife that he divorced became the
fifth
richest person in the world once they
had divorced and the richest
racist in the world mm-hmm how much does
she get
half 50 billion or something no no like
i'm talking about like a percentage
she got i don't know but he's worth i
don't know true she got a small
percentage of what he makes but
in the grand scheme of things it came
out to be billions of millions bring up
how much she made chin
it doesn't matter she's the richest
female she's about to say she comes she
came up she came up
either way he got with lazy eye for a
reason
god you know 62
billion dollars she seems like a
wholesome like yeah come on now
jim pull up a yeah where is she is san
fran right now
i don't know oh no
she's cute cool yeah she's so beautiful
they started together
she looks younger talk to that talk
malik the most beautiful woman i've ever
seen
she was 62 billion yeah his eye right
honestly money doesn't
in the eye of the beholder yeah i guess
yeah yeah he got jacked he got really
jacked yeah he did
what else you when you're a billionaire
it's like dude he might be jacked he
might be auditioning for papa
he's just that pop i have yes
oh he did y'all tripping today yeah he
got super jacked
right there what is it side by side oh
good for him that's vin diesel
yeah but that's how he used to look how
crazy is this nerd
alert what is what happens with money
just money
just makes you look better though well
you have the the
resources the best things in the world
what supplements are you taking jeff
bezos
dude he's on trt he's on human growth
hormones do you
no i know so he's also on the he has the
best chef in the world
best food well i know he probably has
the best because you don't go from that
to that without that stuff
you think so my wife is natural though i
mean fellas it's not
he guys look at this diamond piece girl
oh yeah she's beautiful
yeah she is bad huh yeah that's what
happened when you level up bro
i understand it salute j thick too
though
jay is thick but like jake can lose
weight fast which bothers me
yeah a little jealous i just yeah i have
to like really
yeah i need to when you tighten it up
yeah and you know what like
i guess yeah like looking at the
pictures yeah i don't i'm like how about
us in the mall right and that's how i
knew y'all both had problems
okay we're in the mall and i needed some
new sweats for uh the show
we walked past a cinnabun right now
y'all don't say y'all don't say it the
first time
but as upon as we start walking to the
car
chappelle goes hey brandon what up and
no one knew we just looked around
nah i can't do it right now but why you
want something
where i ain't gonna eat if you gonna eat
it why go eat it now
we were talking about the way we eat the
cinnabon oh my god hold up you get a
dark roast coffee and then you get just
the middles from cinnabun
with extra icing this [ __ ] was a whole
debate by the way this is a whole
we was in a bed it was a full-on
conversation and then it goes at the end
they're like
[ __ ] i kind of want that cinnabun like
what oh yeah i was like [ __ ] i kind of
want that cinnabon
what's weird when i'm on the road i
don't eat that much
don't say that i feel like yeah i didn't
touch any food in the in the dressing
room no
you didn't no i ordered no food i drank
whiskey that's
it oh yeah you did and then we went to
that speakeasy i'd like you to have a
couple pieces of candy you did have a
couple pieces
i had some licorice act like henry studo
didn't eat all the candy
oh yeah bro yeah he yeah
he's a funny dude yeah he's great i love
him great dude so that's the candy right
there so if you look at you zoom in yeah
yeah they brought us fresh candy but
they they know my style it was fresh
candy and then whiskey every night and
henry was like [ __ ]
with the sucker oh there's a sucker
right there he'll take it out that night
brendan photobomb i think i sent it to
you
bring a photo or no no not yet oh man
arizona he photobombed our freaking
photo
looking all thick in the background what
up keith what up keith what up craig
i think he says craig i think what up
craig
i was coming out of the bathroom i think
yeah you're thick dude all right
we're all thick yeah you lose a little
weight
yeah you know what the goal should be
just eat what stevie eats
you know you know what pissed me off and
i called him out when we were eating
chicken wings
these wings were covered listen let's
call it what it is they're delicious
because they're sugar and they're hot
sauce there's some other [ __ ] on them i
couldn't stop they might be cocaine
it was how many did you get eighty well
that's not hope you got eighty chicken
wings
between i probably had twenty it was a
hundred eight twenty it was a hundred i
probably ate like twelve
twenty one you and i both eat i saw your
plate
twelve i know he was sitting right now i
had two places i tore those up we tore
him up
but anyway uh stevie oh had six i know
he wants some more he's
i limit myself to six like yeah and [ __ ]
you
he started eating the celery and carrots
how about how about
and they got real awkward because we
shared a shower kill in the shower i was
like god damn he shredded right now doug
what are you doing because it was in his
old
airbnb oh yeah like it was an ant airbnb
was antique
airbnb was [ __ ] listen all they was
missing was the plastic it was couches
because it looked like my grandmother
house
it looks like somebody's aunt's house
yeah it really it looked like the house
from katy perry's video
uh if you see that one she throws the
party last that's right i know that's
right
and then the car it's a it's a family
house that is and then the car that jay
rented
again dude he if he does this in
nashville i told you i'm gonna fire jake
super super honest mr bc what was that
yeah what was that is that a newer
mitsubishi i i was awful i don't like
japanese i love japanese people i like
their food i like their fashion you like
[ __ ] hate their cars
i hate the electronics the only good
ones the gtr
gtr especially an old gtr but outside
that chin i don't [ __ ] with them i hate
the electronics in japanese cars oh damn
all right well yeah so anyway um yeah
damn i caught steve in the shower shoot
you caught me trying to get two threads
oh my gosh i just had a shirt i was
walking upstairs i just see
ass and i'm like i was like
i was like
talking about just had a white shirt
downstairs i'm trying to find some
toothpaste oh
yeah i'm trying to play like he said it
like this
trying to find toothpaste i don't think
he ate i'll run too you know
downstairs man i can't deal with that
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son
he's an ex-professional basketball
player played overseas yeah
what is that bad yeah you know it's not
nba
it's like the community what about the
[ __ ] the metal the lamello yeah
he was 16 playing come on man it's grown
man come on wait you're allowed to play
at 16 over there if you're that good
yeah chappelle what are you talking
about he's a beast he's super beast
really yeah he went over there and they
make an exception so he can play well
you can do it if you're good enough you
can do it you just
you can't do it here in the states like
you can't go from high school to nba
anymore
because we have those uh child worker
laws no we have uh let's make let's make
college basketball pop
and then you can leave well so some most
people are starting to go to like
overseas and then the g league is going
to start paying like college people
yeah yeah yeah lamelo i mean he did he
did it
it's weird right like people give his
dad [ __ ] but you gotta be a good dad
hello
he's a great three he's all five well
listen two out of three
the other one ain't bad though yeah yeah
stole some [ __ ] in china yeah that's
right i messed with china what he's
still some sunglasses
he stole some sunglasses number one as
pistons trade up if they ever fought his
horn
trade right yeah yeah well you know
minnesota has the number one pick
oh dude you know i started listening to
you know uh the the slim reaper is my
favorite player kevin
kevin garnett kevin uh durant kevin
doing it yeah kevin durant kevin durant
yep uh he just launched the podcast
cameron durandy yeah i thought kyrie
ever wait he did
well he had kyrie irving on his first as
a guest it's good
really are you serious yeah it's really
he's really surprisingly really good at
it
who was on it i was a guy that's going
to be some [ __ ] and even though i
love kevin greiner i was going to be
some [ __ ] kevin durant
and the guy yeah kevin durant the guy
his co-host
eddie gonzalez is really good who's
eddie gonzalez i don't know
i don't know because you know i'm always
on my bike for like two and a half hours
so i'm constantly looking for shows to
listen to while i write her books
and then uh this popped up no you know i
heard
i heard charlemagne talking about it i
think i'm brilliant idiots
oh yeah he's because i don't know if
it's on his network or what
somehow i got uh savvy to it and it was
dope
what were they discussing like just like
basically like kyrie's come up in new
york playing street ball
his dad and his uncle and his uncle was
in the nba and how he knew he was gifted
like he was like
when i was 17 month old uh in the
hospital i was dribbling a basketball
and his dad because they were there i
think for her sister and his dad was
like quit dribbling in the hospital and
the doctor's like no
let him dribble all he wants really
they're like let him do it we've never
seen a 17 month old do this
like let him dribble all around and he
was saying how
uh when he was like in fifth grade his
dad would just have him doing like crazy
[ __ ]
he wanted to do it but he sounded like
super focused
and then the eddie gonzalez goes when
did you know you're gonna make the nba
he was in eighth grade
damn yeah he was like in eighth grade
because he said
um in new york like on the weekends the
kids games were like super competitive
and he just he said the friday night
before he like couldn't sleep he's so
excited
not because he just wanted to ball out
because of the competition
and then he then he said he went from
there to new jersey like the suburbs
because he got a scholarship
in high school to play for like some
prep team it was like suburbans he kept
saying suburban kids
white kids yeah and he was like it's
just not their
like they had other things like their
goals were to be accountants and
entrepreneurs he's like and i want to be
a basketball player he's like
so he's averaging whatever 60 points or
some [ __ ] he's like but the competition
was good
so he dipped out of there and went back
to the borough of new york yeah
and it was like just stepped his game
and he became a prodigy dude it was dope
yeah it was a dope
and then him and uh durant talk about
competing against each other and kobe
yeah yeah it's dope and then he show he
throws a little shade
lebron i heard it because he goes he
goes yeah for the first time my career i
can actually because
because eddie gonzalez goes hey i'm not
even trying to make headlines or
anything like this he goes when they say
that they but he goes
you know i doubt he was he well yeah i
think the question
well he was he goes i'm not trying to
make headlines anything he goes but
what's it like playing with kevin durant
you know
kyrie irving's played with you know
lebron his main game yeah yeah
although he did win the championship
game seven hit the game but he hasn't
fully played what kevin
did no they they've never played
together yeah well i think i'm the
question on the olympic team maybe well
but they're playing they're on the team
now they're on the team now
so he said you know what's gonna be like
playing kevin durant he said for the
first time my career
i can actually pass the ball with the la
with the game on the line and feel
comfortable about it
and they're like ooh okay yeah i'm not
going to do that
we don't want to get into that no no no
we'll but but this is what's dope
he's talking about kobe like he was
saying how he was
uh i forget what olympic year it was but
he was like on the
alternative team and kobe was in there
like getting ice and stuff like this
and he said kobe was known for he was
just like you know he's kobe like he had
an aura around him like a prickly dude
and he went up to him to to ask him
something and he said kobe was kind of
cool
and he said he heard years later that
kobe went back to his he went to dinner
that night it was like this kid tyrone
knew
he came up and tried talking to me you
believe that [ __ ] he talking to me
damn kyrie was like damn for real yeah
but then they got super close
bonded he said he attacks him after
every game and like if before he was
going to make a trade you know
go to another team at texas kobe see
what he thought of it yeah did you guys
just had to warm up to each other did
you see the video of kobe uh talking
[ __ ] to kyrie irving
no what on when there was on the olympic
team it's the best thing ever like
he's a kyrie irving young guy and kobe
is like get out you know
it's it's great he's like just giving
him a little hazing them basically
yeah now kyrie irving has the best
handles in the league that's what
that's if maybe ever but let me know him
or
iverson let him or steph curry steph
curry handles are crazy who would you
give it to
who would i rather have on my team yeah
be a steph curry or kyrie that's a great
question
would you rather have another you're
starting your team you're a gm kyrie
who's injury prone okay or stephanie
i'll tell you who i wrote steph curry
just missed the whole season right
so how cool is this this guy actually
created it this dad recreated uh the
madhorn disneyland's matterhorn in his
backyard i haven't watched this video
yet so we'll watch it together
copy that four minutes well i'll fast
forward it
turn the music down dad's a beast he did
this for his son can you imagine this is
your dad
it's so great just making the dopest
things
wow that's sick though
you know what matterhorn is pretty small
in general yeah it is tall
yeah wow look here it goes that looks
great
that looks so dangerous because it's so
like narrow i know right
and also like a kid's 18 yeah
not really a kid i didn't think about
that weird i didn't think about that
but it's also not electric that's just
on wheels yeah
you know it's still cool i hate to hate
on it yeah you gotta scoot it up like
dad buy me a car
that thing's no giant backyard too
[Music]
well there you go how long did it take
did they say that i'm sure they they
said it
would be cool yeah especially if you've
had a kid for the sun
he's a little too old for that but
that's cool his big ass
is that rob lowe it is it is
great picture all right well i don't see
it but that's good that's pretty cool
yeah let's go that is extra time hold on
15 world rosie hot shots oh sorry
sorry about that this one i saw i don't
know someone sent this in but this is
a little wild it's not even a brand new
video but i'll just play it for you
i'm very unique you'll know what's
happening in this section because why
you got so much pee
i'll be out 10 years
give him a shake give him a [ __ ]
both officers are all right yo that's so
funny ah
great comment why does he have so much
piss sounds like this was in the uk
yeah i'm gonna bang you up give it a
shake
all righty um